[Music]
none of us really know each other her
all screw-ups but somehow we were all in
the same place at the same time when
Billy found those coins
guys she's out how we glow I'm blue oh
I'm black what I hear no no no but
strong say nice try
the answer to what is happening to you
is here you five are the Power Rangers
did I just you say work Power Rangers
this one got a joke we're talking to a
wall I was kind of expecting a little
more so where were you last night me and
four kids found a spaceship buried
underground I'm pretty sure I'm a
superhero
cool pick in that Cup Power Rangers were
a legion of warriors you must become
those warriors it's the hologram like a
video game that's a strong gas hologram
on a video you were born to this destroy
everything she is cured evil
how do you expect us to stop her
it's morphin time so we're better than
anybody ever seen
there's a lot of gold
this is your destiny
this is your time
this heart of mine I can't so this is
where you come every Saturday instead of
practice
tragic